[Music]
guys we've all been there before you
booked the day off you're getting ready
to watch your favorite eSports
competition featuring the best players
in the world and then everything goes to
[ __ ] final it is set to go live it
liquid looking for some revenge for
their fallen North American brethren as
they after all guys eSports hasn't
always been the big production that it
is today and well nowadays you're used
to top to your production from your
favorite tournaments there was a time
when going to a big land event was a bit
of a dice roll so we thought why not
reminisce and take a look back at some a
sports tournaments from years past then
didn't quite go as planned here are the
top 10 worst eSports tournaments so far
kicking off our list is none other than
the nan yang dota 2 championships Cruz
Cup shortly after being fired from the
Shanghai major ki TV decided it would be
a good idea to host a 14 tournament on a
cruise ship the tournament director
claimed that they were renting a
satellite to ensure a quality stream but
struggled to keep the broadcast running
if it wasn't before it quickly became
clear aboard the sapphire princess that
the cruise was less of a dota tournament
than a vacation with lots of poker and
video games this was never meant to be a
normal competition and couldn't be with
the numerous obstacles and uncertainties
of playing at sea even the eventual
winners wings gaming left with a sour
taste in their mouths you literally had
to be there to experience it
taking the number 9 spot on our list is
the electronic Sports World Cup 2015 in
Montreal ESWC was run by mundial de jour
and despite having run events before the
tournament ran into the typical issues
were used to experiencing from subpar
tournaments we'll get into them in a
second but first a short break I have a
high of a magic word for all of you we
are going for a quick break we will be
right back
are we really are we really okay so I do
have some news for you guys guys we are
going to take a short commercial break
and we will be back okay held during a
heatwave in Montreal the server's
overheated on the first day and were
ddosed on the second-leading two long
delays that would tire out even the most
die-hard csgo fan trust us we were there
coming in at number eight is world cyber
arena 2015 taking place in Yunshan China
in December the climate was extremely
cold which wouldn't normally be an issue
outside of the fact that the venue was
an hour away from the hotels and the
buses apparently didn't have heating and
that's only the beginning plastic chairs
and tiny tables were crammed together
there was reportedly no place for the
teams to rest
I saw the players from Empire and I was
very shocked I don't know how to
describe the place to you all very
narrow very crammed like the cheap
internet cafes besides schools you saw a
few years back teams played across from
each other leading to accusations of
cheating because they could hear each
other's calls this actually sounds to me
like it is the worst front tournament
we'll see it's you guys agree or do you
think it's closed or what so come it all
up guys [ __ ] WCA coming in at number
seven is the ESL esea Dubai Invitational
2015 for some reason Dubai's tourism
group thought it would be a great idea
to host a gaming tournament in an
outdoor venue the event was meant to
take place in the evening when
temperatures would be a little more
bearable but with all the bodies and PCs
running it didn't quite work out the way
it was planned alright I here and down
in what can only be described as the
heat of it it is hot down here
the fans are awesome and they are
cheering for their favourite teams games
had to be played off stage earlier in
the day due to poor scheduling and
planning which led to attendees missing
out on a lot of the action it is the ESL
esea Pro League Dubai Invitational here
we are getting ourselves a little ahead
of schedule let's just say we're gonna
be kicking off with two games who are
actually meant we played backstage they
are still backstage if I'm honest but
we're casting a hair from the venue it's
a little bit more downtempo it's a
little bit car throw together probably
should have stayed home for this one
coming in at number six is the major
all-stars dota 2 tournament major
all-stars took place in Malaysia in
March of 2015 and was touted to be the
largest dota 2 tournament ever held in
Southeast Asia due to internet outages
and hardware issues the first game took
more than five hours to complete there
was some big power surge that melted as
a significant part of the venue where
they had to redo all of the cabling now
that wouldn't have been all that bad
except that the player rooms apparently
had plastic chairs and were infested
with cockroaches by the time the games
did get running both on stage English
casters were tasked with observing with
audio coming from the venue speakers
right next to their desk so the
dedicated obstacles we had to computers
one of them was doing dedicated avec one
of the casters had to do dedicated
obvious and the other caster or the co
caster was doing the dedicated obscene
at the front of the venue that everybody
in the venue was watching we're at the
bottom of the court facing the stage
right
before the stadium seating starts so
we're like prime positioning for the PA
to be blaring as the Russian in
Vietnamese casters were not so lucky as
they had to persist through PC problems
thankfully there is a slight happy
ending to this story
according to joindota the eventual
winners Invictus gaming receive their
full prize money two years after the
tournament ended at the halfway point on
our list is iron gaming season 1 having
previously produced Halo tournaments
iron gaming hosted their first csgo LAN
in July of 2014
iron gaming had a bad rep of producing
subpar tournaments and this csgo event
was no different alright guys welcome
back to the second semi-final match up
it is gonna be me and going up against
Armada joined here with Benson hey I'm
excited I I can't wait you know it's
about time I go back in the booth
together the incredible duo after the
disaster of an event the company hosted
an AMA and gave excuses which were
quickly disproven by key community
figures and if that wasn't enough get
right tweeted out in 2017 that they
never received the full payment for
winning the event huh should have seen
that one coming we all saw the number
for entry in this list coming and few
tournaments remind eSports fans of poor
production more than valves infamous
Shanghai major now production issues are
forgivable after all [ __ ] happens even
at a three million dollar tournament but
Shanghai was on a whole nother level of
disaster hello and welcome to the
Shanghai major presented by perfect
world we're live and police monitored
and an undisclosed location I am sir -
good your host for this event after the
public firing of James - good Harding
and the original production team in key
TV the broadcast tightened up but things
were falling apart behind the scenes as
well alright so the welcoming ceremony
was actually cancelled or something
production value from poor scheduling to
awful accommodations the players and
talent persevered but even after the
tournament had ended the nightmare
continued as equipment was lost by the
hotel staff and local authorities were
even involved our number three entry
takes us to the island of Saint Maarten
in the Caribbean where vxg took place
vxg was claimed to be the greatest
tournament in fighting game history when
vxg is done and I'm telling you right
now vxg will be the greatest event in
fighting game history it is going to set
a new standard a new template you are
going to be caught between East Coast or
down evolution and then the aftermath
which is vxg organized by triforce the
owner of empire arcadia notable players
attended the event despite his
reputation of not fulfilling his
promises before they were set to begin
the top eight players were asked to sign
a contract that stated they would
receive 33% of their prize money after
the event while the remainder would be
paid out at a later date the only
problem is that they weren't and they
never received their full payout oh yeah
and there was also an alleged
match-fixing scandal during the MVC
three finals as well
that was nine we didn't plan
we didn't say we were gonna do it we
didn't it was not play it just happened
I think YouTube accident what a disaster
we're taking you all the way back to
2012's India gaming carnival for our
runner-up spot the tournament was
supposed to be one of the biggest events
of the year with a more than $300,000
prize pool for featured games India
gaming carnival had all the usual issues
you'd expect such as poor player
conditions and equipment but it's not
often you end up at an eSports
tournament fearing for your life
moscowfive or one of the international
teams that attended the event despite
receiving warnings from fnatic and natus
vincere the team ended up reaching the
semi-finals at which point the
organisers decided to actually shut down
the entire event by cutting off the
electricity as well as all contact with
the teams as the team was waiting for a
taxi to return to their hotel they
spotted four thug-like men that followed
them even after they got into their taxi
when they woke up their room had been
broken into and robbed of money as well
as an 8 gigabyte memory stick containing
footage of the entire [ __ ] show you
can't make this [ __ ] up taking the top
spot on our list for most disasters
tournament of all time is gaming
paradise which contrary to its name was
anything but for everyone involved [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] event that has ever
happened to the point where people are
literally grateful to cow of the country
with their lives let alone their [ __ ]
prize money seriously gaming paradise
should have just been called gaming hell
as it had all the tell-tale signs of a
poorly run tournament for starters ban
hardware that didn't show up on time
causing hours of stream delays yes the
computers were set up at 6 p.m. at the
of the event which should have started
at 9:00 a.m. the hotels in production
equipment weren't paid for which led to
players passports being held by the
hotel and the police being called when
we figure out that the the venue isn't
paid their hotels in didn't wasn't paid
we thought okay what's what what's with
the if nothing is paid when how can we
expect that players will get their prize
money if when they win the dota 2
tournament was cancelled altogether and
to cap it all off according to g2
eSports then tightened the csgo prize
money was never paid out our own daniel
rossen said it best esports production
has come a long way in the last couple
of years so remember next time you're
completing and twitch at about how bad a
tournament seems to you it could have
been a lot worse it could have been
gaming paradise guys trust me when I say
that top 10 list was as hard for us to
make as it was for you to watch and I
just hope we never have to do a part 2
and if you are interested in taking a
bit of a deeper dive into our number one
entry that would be gaming paradise why
not check out our full-length video on
that very tournament titled the worst
csgo tournament ever seriously that [ __ ]
was worse than fighter festival thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button